now what is that well you don't know
what this is yet
you haven't met this chief yet but
suffice to say it is a parametric sorry
it is a Cartesian equation now what
Cartesian equation is it well sorry you
can't quite see here's my 1 + 2 10 theta
I've just used theater and teens that
it's easier to write for this and here's
my 3 sec - 4 is that okay so here's my
x-coordinate it's just underneath this
black bit and here's my y-coordinate
okay now the whole point of this is that
now as I change the parameter both x and
y change simultaneously right so one
value pushes the whole thing around so
now when I play I want you to have a
look at what this point is doing right
this is why we introduced locus before
we started talking about this because
this point down here is kind of like you
guys moving around right but it's moving
around in a certain way it's not just
moving around anywhere
it's tracing out a very particular shape
how would you describe this thing it
kind of at a certain point up here it
kind of what does that kind of look like
sort of looks like a parabola but then
it does this guy like oh hold on a
second yeah how can you be two parabolas
at the same time okay so we just worked
out what the Cartesian equation was
right okay you stop moving
we'll put this Cartesian equation in
what do we got here so I think we've got
nine outside of where we got X minus one
minus one squared it's a - isn't it -
four outside of one plus four squared by
the way just before I move on from that
we've met with functions and
transformations that kind of thing we
know what the minus one like forget
about the fact that you don't know what
the shape is when you see X minus one
would that mean it means a of one unit
to the right yeah and what about this
four units downwards which is y by the
way have a look at where everything
seems to be happening it seems to be
moving over this way right I think this
is what do we got let me finish it off
that equals negative
thirty-six what is that well let's see
if we got it right hey guy hmm uh yeah
that's because my values don't go
forever
they just yeah so it loops back you can
see that's where it lose back go center
now I'm what is this shape
well you you're not very familiar with
it in this orientation but if you do
your favor and just um lend your head
about 45 degrees to the left
okay can you see it now maybe if I put
in an extra a couple of things here you
might see it a little more clearly I put
in a line here and a line there is a
little more familiar now what is this
thing this is a hyperbola right it's the
same kind of hyperbola you've been
dealing with for years except it's often
an angle right and that's why it has
this weird funky equation like this but
that's the shape that's the Cartesian
equation okay
be thankful you don't really have to
deal with heaps of depth about this it's
an extension to topic even they get
confused about it but there you go you
write it out okay